all right during maxwell's trial we got
an inside look into jeffrey epstein's
manhattan mansion photographs taken by
federal investigators which you can now
see
on your screen show epstein had several
boxes of hard drives that were oddly
covered in evidence tape investigators
also took photos of numerous black
binders and cds which contained
additional evidence and in some cases
allegedly child pornography the federal
judge in the case ruled some of the
labels on these binders were quote
identifying information for third
parties so they were redacted
investigators also found this completely
bizarre painting on your screen now of
bill clinton in a blue dress
so
who should be
most worried tonight is it bill clinton
is it prince andrew nancy grace is the
host of crime stories on fox nation and
she joins us now nancy thank you for
jumping on with us who do you think
sleeps uneasily tonight
well that's obvious to me the person
that's sleeping the least tonight is
gallane maxwell
because she's headed to a federal pen
which one i don't know her sentencing is
coming up and it's not been scheduled
but she's looking at 65 years behind
bars so let me just take one moment and
bask in the moment
of justice
finally handed down
long delayed now will gelain maxwell
sing
for her supper will she name names
possibly but remember even with her
naming names that case has to be proven
with victims that will come forward and
if you want to name a president an
ex-president a wealthy individual if you
want to name leon black or whoever
that's got to be corroborated in court
now that will be the trick will elaine
maxwell wrap people out very likely
although she was pretty stoic in the
courtroom today one of her lawyers broke
down in tears in front of god and
everybody but maxwell stayed cool one
last look back at her family and she
walked out of the courtroom
i don't know if she's going to crack
so on our screen right now is a picture
of chelsea clinton's wedding you can see
bill clinton walking her down the aisle
highlighted in the background there is
galen maxwell
at that wedding there is also pictures
on your screen of bill clinton at
various times flashing up receiving a
massage you know
it's true as you said nancy it's just as
tonight that glenn maxwell sleeps
uneasily behind bars but i think
everyone watching is concerned that
justice stops here which would be an
injustice because clearly she was
trafficking these young women to other
people to individuals and you would have
to suspect beyond jeffrey epstein the
prosecution has shown very little
interest in fact they've discouraged any
names coming out in this trial
quote-unquote third parties and so i
have to wonder with everything found in
his apartment
cds binders nancy will we get those
names beyond whether or not they will be
corroborated will somebody ask nancy
will we pursue that next step in justice
i believe with all the heat on federal
prosecutors right now that they will go
forward that they will explore the
possibilities within all of those
binders it's hard to keep a secret like
that there were detectives there were
investigators there were crime scene
texts everywhere they saw all of that i
find it very difficult to believe that
they would keep it all under their hat
for what propriety that's not going to
happen if in fact the evidence to which
you are referring exists
right and speaking of that evidence
nancy what do you make of what was
catalogued inside of jeffrey epstein's
apartment
well if it had anything to do with these
particular victims the four women that
came forward very very bravely it would
have been brought out at trial
if it's got to do with other alleged
victims they've got to be hunted down
track down
coerced to testify
uh let me say encouraged to move forward
with a lot stacked against them and
that's going to be a very daunting task
but i believe with so many people at the
crime scene it's very possible names
will be named
it will be an injustice if this is the
end of the story and not the beginning
yes it will if there are other
perpetrators no matter how prestigious
they may be no matter how wealthy they
may be if they are not sought out and
prosecuted that is an injustice lady
justice wears a blindfold for a reason
she is not to care about your wealth or
your education or your status
that's why she is depicted the way she
is and it is an injustice if that
investigation is not completed
nancy grace thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else